[Music]
your
I feel safer cuz I think any more
technology is better little no because I
prefer for people to be for cops that
are actual humans to be in the area I
think there's a chance it'll make it
safer sure no at this point I'm not sure
just because I haven't really been able
to see it in action it's exciting I
think um the more we can use technology
in our everyday lives the better I guess
it makes me feel a little bit more safe
at night as somebody who's not from here
like to to know like there's something
uh kind of watching over it's going that
way anyway regardless there's cameras
everywhere and they're monitoring you so
it's just another add-on to the uh crime
prevention whatever they can do to make
us safer and come on look at look at the
robot you it's like a it's like a from
Doctor Who something from Doctor
Who a bad kind of you I think it's cute
it definitely makes me feel a bit safer
knowing that there's another set of eyes
around
um also it looks fairly robust so that
helps too um in case of any um you know
suspicious activity that people might be
deterred I don't know how he would make
me feel safe cuz I'm not sure what type
of um I guess attack he would have I
don't think robotics is Advanced far
enough yet you know we're still running
people over with autonomously driven
vehicles I keep wondering what's going
to happen with all the stairs and how
he's going to react to all the stairs
that are available in um Time Square CU
as you can see there are stairs pretty
much everywhere in this station I I
think it will help safety do you know
that there's people that throw uh you
know mentally ill uh uh people that
throw uh uh other passengers on the
trails like and the cops are not always
there so I'm sure that you know uh uh
the robbert is going to be able to
somehow you know keep things uh under
control I don't travel the subway when
there's trouble right so I'm a
mainstreamer but but if there were 11:00
at night I'd love to see a couple of
cops on the I've felt safe we've been
here for 5 days now and I felt safe and
there are so many demands on on people
to find more employees that anything to
help the NYPD has has got to be a plus
technology can always
malfunction um and so to rely on a piece
of technology to keep a human safe if
you come in contact with another human
who doesn't have good intentions it's
kind of scary I don't know if I feel
safe in either situation um but um I do
know like I don't know if people people
sometimes find a way around technology
sometimes and things like that well the
problem with the robotics is they can't
really differentiate between the bad
people and the good people but if I have
a shirt on that says kill everyone and
I'm holding an AR-15 I'm not sure it can
recognize that's a problem I think that
they should Implement more cops that are
humans more Citywide if they have the
resources to do that um I think this is
like a camera like it helps to have a
camera taking footage of things that are
happening but again we it'd be more
helpful for me and I'd feel more safe if
there was an actual human someday
artificial intelligence and Robotics
will keep us all safe but we're not
there
[Music]
yet